bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat pour une séance qui
devait être principalement consacrée à
la simplification des normes mais
c'était sans compter une annonce qui
n'en finit plus de faire des vagues
il s'agit de l'annoncé faite ce matin
par le premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault sur france inter il a indiqué
que la loi sur le logement avait été
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
alors que l'institution présidée par
jean louis debré doit seulement statuer
aujourd'hui en fin d'après-midi un
cafouillage gouvernemental dénoncé par
l'opposition sénatoriale à travers un
déluge de rappel au règlement que je
vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
bon après midi à tous j'ai un certain
nombre de rappels au règlement la parole
est à monsieur roger karoutchi pour
l'ump le président mesdames les
ministres
mon rappel au règlement se fonde sur
l'article 29 terre de notre règlement du
sénat
nous avons eu la surprise ce matin sur
une radio d'entendre le premier ministre
a annoncé qu'un nouveau texte sur le
logement serait proposé au parlement
dans un mois et demi
le premier ministre annonce une décision
du conseil constitutionnel
plusieurs heures avant que le conseil
constitutionnel n'annonce sa décision
le premier ministre pense probablement
peu le conseil constitutionnel que le
titre 7 de notre constitution mais au
dessus de tout cela et en autorités
totalement indépendante que le conseil
peut avoir un porte parole
gouvernemental
j'ignorais que la rue montpensier était
devenu le pavillon de musique des
jardins de matignon
là dessus je crois maintenant qu'il faut
que les règles soient respectées
le premier ministre n'a pas à annoncer
les décisions je ne sais pas moi si tout
à l'air le conseil constitutionnel va
décider ou non de l'annulation de ce
texte
et si jamais il le décide et il ya une
deuxième incongruité dans les propos du
premier ministre ce matin je voudrais
attirer l'attention de nos collègues de
la majorité sénatoriale
le premier ministre dit ce matin ce
texte annulé laissons lui la
responsabilité de l'annulation ce texte
annulé et du un cafouillage
parlementaire
alors moi je trouve quand même que là
dessus
sauf si monsieur bell veut revendiquer
le cafouillage lui même ça c'est autre
chose
mais enfin qui et qui fait quoi dans
cette république c'est l'exécutif qui
convoque la session extraordinaire du
parlement
c'est l'exécutif qui a d'abord convoqué
le 26 septembre il pique à avancer au 11
septembre
c'est l'exécutif qui a mis en
délibération au conseil des ministres le
texte sur le logement
six jours seulement avant de le
transmettre au sénat c'est l'exécutif
qui n'a pas respecté les délais ni pour
les commissions ni pour les droit
d'amendement ni pour l'étude d'impact
c'est l'exécutif qui n'a pas laissé la
possibilité d'avoir le texte de la
commission en séance plénière il n'y a
pas de cafouillage parlementaire il y à
un cafouillage gouvernemental
il ya un cafouillage et une
impréparation du côté du gouvernement
une précipitation peut être dû au fait
qu'ils avaient avancé la date de la
session extraordinaire mais la
responsabilité si tenté qu'il y ait une
annulation tout à l'heure c'est la seule
responsabilité du gouvernement
le parlement a fait son travail que le
gouvernement fasse le sien alors je vous
demande je vous demande monsieur le
président que demandait au président du
sénat une correction du propos du
premier ministre parce qu'il est
inacceptable de dire que s'il ya une
annulation c'est de la faute du
parlement alors que c'est de la faute du
gouvernement et je ne doute pas que le
président de la république garant de nos
institutions
rappel à l'ordre l'ensemble des membres
du gouvernement
le gouvernement est à la disposition du
parlement et le parlement et l'autorité
souveraine en matière de lois
cela doit être dit et respectée et c'est
la deuxième fois que le conseil
constitutionnel censure le gouvernement
sur des pratiques qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être
moi je me souviens delà des débats sur
la réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 où
monsieur ayrault président
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale me disais sans arrêt vous
n'êtes pas sérieux monsieur le ministre
les ces six semaines aux commissions
laisser le délai d'amendements respecter
le parlement
le bafouer pas les droits du parlement
eh bien monsieur le premier ministre
respecter nos droits merci chers
collègues je vous donne naturellement
acte et je transmets club
la parole est à mme catherine twain le
pour le groupe ump monsieur le président
c'est également un rappel au règlement
sans doute avec moins de panache que
monsieur karoutchi
mais je m'y attache serait quand même je
souhaiterais faire un rappel au
règlement concernant l'organisation de
nos travaux sur les fondements de
l'article 29 terre de notre règlement le
président de la république et le
président du sénat on souhaitait l'un et
l'autre à leur manière rappelé leur
attachement aux collectivités
territoriales et surtout à la question
de la confiance mutuelle qui devait
prévaloir entre l'état et les
collectivités
et pourtant lors de la conférence des
présidents du 26 septembre dernier
j'avais demandé au nom de mon groupe et
pour l'intérêt que suscite le débat que
nous ouvrons cette après midi pour
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales que nous représentons que
le sénat ouvre la séance de ce soir afin
que la discussion de ce sujet puisse non
pas s'éterniser
mais se poursuivre dans le but d'aboutir
à l'adoption d'un texte qui apporte une
réelle amélioration pour les élus locaux
or la conférence des présidents décidé
que ces discussions serait figé dans un
délai de quatre heures aux motifs comme
nous l'avait rappelé le président du
sénat que nous avions pris la ferme
résolution de ne pas dépasser les temps
imparti à chaque groupe bénéficiant d'un
espace réservé nous en avons pris acte
tout en décidant comme vous le verrez
tout à l'heure lors de la discussion des
amendements de rester ferme sur notre
position essentiellement sur l'article
1er qui est selon nous la clé de voûte
des relations de confiance que l'état
doit entretenir avec les collectivités
quelle n'a pas été notre surprise
lorsque nous avons découvert lundi en
milieu de journée que le groupe
socialiste avait déposé plus de trente
amendements très certainement pour
l'amélioration substantielle du texte
l'expérience qui est la nôtre
l'expérience qui est la vôtre montre
qu'il est impossible d'examiner autant
d'amendements dans le créneau un parti
de quatre heures d'autant plus que
plusieurs commissions se sont saisies
pour avis que chacun sait que sur les
quatre heures de débats deux heures
seront consacrées à la discussion
générale discussions que nous avons déjà
vu en février dernier lors de
l'inscription de ce texte déjà dans
notre espace réservé nous y voyons donc
une réelle volonté du groupe socialiste
de ne pas faire aboutir la discussion de
ce texte d'ici la fin de cette séance
empêchant ainsi les élus locaux d'être
enfin satisfait du travail de notre que
notre majorité a pu accomplir ce sujet
nous y voyons la volonté du groupe
socialiste de faire en sorte que ce
texte ne soit pas adoptée afin de
privilégier par une technique
d'obstruction bien connue des futurs
textes présentés par le groupe
socialiste au palais gouvernement sur
des sujets essentiels pour les
collectivités territoriales
enfin et c est cela vient d'être porté à
ma connaissance une motion de renvoi en
commission étaient déposés par les
membres du groupe crc
c'est faire bien mais bien c'est faire
peu de cas mes chers collègues des nuits
mois de travail consacrée par la
commission à ce texte
chers collègues voilà une bien curieuse
conception des travail des travaux
parlementaires
merci chers collègues acte est donné
la parole est à monsieur françois
zocchetto présidons président du groupe
de l'union des démocrates indépendants
uc merci monsieur le président au risque
d'être redondant j'exprimerai également
les opinions du groupe u10 us et
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues je demande
en effet un rappel au règlement au titre
de l'article 16 de notre règlement et au
titre des articles 5 21 45 et 61 de la
constitution
cela nous a sans doute échappé mais nous
ne savions pas qu'il y avait eu révision
constitutionnelle pendant l'été depuis
quand le premier ministre se fait-il
juge constitutionnel avant le conseil
constitutionnel lui-même
j'ai eu beau relire plusieurs fois
l'article 21 de la constitution relatif
aux fonctions du premier ministre je
n'ai trouvé aucune trace d'une telle
interprétation qui aurait permis au
premier ministre de devenir juge
constitutionnel
en revanche l'article 5 de notre
constitution est très claire il fait du
président de la république le gardien de
la constitution et je dois dire que dans
les circonstances qui ont été décrites
notamment par notre collègue karoutchi
tout à l'heure nous attendons la
réaction du président de la république
avec impatience
chers collègues ce énième événement
alimente un feuilleton de mauvais goût
ou le des gouvernements ni les règles
constitutionnelles d'examen des textes
et bafoue outrageusement les droits du
parlement
nous savions déjà que le gouvernement
depuis quelques mois faisait fi des
prérogatives parlementaires
mais cette fois ci c'est encore plus
fort le gouvernement bafoue et le
parlement et le conseil constitutionnel
nous ne savions pas que le changement
consistait à renverser les principes de
base de la démocratie constitutionnelle
ne savions pas que le changement
permettait de mettre en cause le
principe de la séparation des pouvoirs
je crois pouvoir le dire sous la vème
république c'est du jamais vu au moins
jean marc ayrault restera dans les
mémoires comme le seul premier ministre
à avoir réussi
à bafouer le parlement et le conseil
constitutionnel dans la même matinée la
performance mérite d'être relevé dans
ces circonstances nous en appelons au
président du sénat monsieur le président
vous êtes le défenseur de nos droits
vous êtes le défenseur de notre
assemblée
l'article 16 du règlement indique que
c'est le président du sénat qui transmet
les textes aux commissions c'est le
président du sénat qui doit veiller à la
qualité l'ordre du jour en conférence
des présidents
je sais que les circonstances sont
difficiles pour vous le projet de loi
logement nous a été présenté dans des
conditions si pitoyable que la
commission n'a pas été en mesure de
présenter son rapport
disons le très clairement cela n'a pas
été la responsabilité d'un sénateur
quelconque qu'ils soient de la
commission concernée ou qu'il soit
extérieur à cette commission
aucun sénateur des responsables de ces
circonstances aucun fonctionnaire du
sénat les responsables de ces
circonstances c'est le gouvernement le
gouvernement lui même qui sous couvert
d'ailleurs du président de la république
a sciemment ignoré les acquis de la
révision constitutionnelle du 23 juillet
2008 pour faire de l'affichage purement
politique au moment où la presse
commençait à critiquer l'inaction du
gouvernement
le groupe u10 us et que je représente
ici dénonce cette politique d'amateurs
oui c'est une véritable politique de
gribouille de vian pour on peut même le
dire qui est orchestrée par le
gouvernement et qui est jouée devant nos
chers collègues vous pouvez vous boucher
les oreilles mais les circonstances sont
tout à fait grave
chers collègues de tous les bancs cette
situation est inacceptable
absolument inacceptable et je vous
annonce que nous avec
enfin mes collègues centristes et moi
même nous allons dans les semaines qui
viennent ce sera une contribution très
modeste qui n'est sans doute pas à la
mesure de l'événement que nous vivons
mais nous allons déposer une proposition
de résolution visant à limiter à
l'avenir de telles dérives et nous
demanderons qu'il soit inscrit une bonne
fois pour toute dans notre règlement des
dispositions qui assurent enfin le
respect et la sérénité dont nous avons
besoin pour conduire nos travaux
remerciés merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame valérie létard
pour le groupe u10 us et monsieur le
président mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues
moi aussi je vais m'attarder sur le même
sujet mais je pense que un tel événement
mérite vraiment qu'on s'y attarde
alors je demande à mon tour un rappel au
règlement titre d article 29 g29 bis
nous sommes bien sûr scandalisé par
l'attitude du gouvernement dans
l'interminable feuilleton de la
discussion du projet de loi relatif à la
mobilisation du foncier public en faveur
du logement et au renforcement de la loi
dite sru
le gouvernement a trouvé aujourd'hui
comme chacun l'a rappelé un nouveau bouc
émissaire le parlement lui même
en effet mes chers collègues la censure
d'ores et déjà annoncé et on sait dans
quelles conditions cela a été annoncé de
ce projet de loi ne serait donc pour le
premier ministre comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur karoutchi que le fait d'un
cafouillage parlementaire mais de qui se
moque t'on ce texte nous a été présenté
dans des délais insoutenable jamais nous
n'avions eu encore à discuter en séance
publique
un texte présenté en conseil des
ministres moins d'une semaine avant
faisant ainsi fi de tous les délais
comme l'a rappelé notre président de
groupe il ya un instant et pourtant
dépit de ce calendrier ubuesque notre
haute assemblée a produit un travail de
qualité
l'opposition s'est mobilisée pour
déposer les amendements qui lui
paraissait indispensable et ne dépend
séance publique ont été aussi
approfondie et nourris que possible en
l'absence d'un examen normale en
commission nous nous sommes mobilisés
élus fonctionnaires parlementaires et
collaborateurs pour entrer dans le
détail de ce projet de loi
tout cela dans une course contre la
montre aggraver encore par la
perspective d'une lecture unique du à
l'inscription procédure accélérée alors
même que ce texte sur un sujet complexe
est vital pour nos concitoyens une
méritée de bénéficier des apports d'une
navette parlementaire et aujourd'hui on
voudrait faire porter sur le parlement
la responsabilité d'une erreur qui est
avant tout la faute du gouvernement
cafouillage il y a eu mais c'est un non
pas douter ailleurs que dans cet
hémicycle qu'il faut le chercher après
la torpeur de l'été
vint le temps de l'action dans la
précipitation et à trop vouloir se
précipiter
on finit par se prendre les pieds dans
le tapis oui madame la ministre
votre gouvernement a été pris en
flagrant délit d'incompétence et cette
incompétence ne va pénaliser qu'une
seule et unique cible les français car
c'est au nom des français c'est au nom
de nos concitoyens que vous avez
justifié cette parodie de procédure
c'est au nom de l'urgence face à la
souffrance de nos trop nombreux
concitoyens qui sont mal logés et que
vous vous êtes assis sur le respect des
représentants du peuple et des
institutions de la république et nous
pouvons aujourd'hui malheureusement en
juger les résultats
si le conseil constitutionnel se
prononce cet après midi dans le sens
annoncée par le premier ministre ce
matin votre projet de loi devra être
redéposer rediscuter alors certes cette
fois ci la procédure sera respectée mais
d'ici là ce sont nos concitoyens qui
feront les frais de ce nouveau délai je
joins donc pas voué à celle du président
ok tôt pour que le président du sénat
prenne ses responsabilités car derrière
le respect de notre institution derrière
le respect de nos procédures
constitutionnelles
ce sont les français que l'on protège on
protège leurs droits on protège
également leurs attentes
une telle attitude n'est pas tolérable
et la moindre des choses après une telle
mascarade serait que le premier ministre
adresse des excuses à l'ensemble du
parlement députés comme sénateur je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean louis
masson pour les non-inscrits pour un
rappel au règlement
bon rassurez vous c'est pas sur le même
sujet est hélas hélas bon le président
ano qui représentait non inscrits est
intervenu il y à un mois et demi à peu
près auprès de différentes instances et
notamment au sein de la commission des
finances pour souligner que les délais
de traitement des dossiers de réserve
parlementaire deviennent absolument
prohibitif on n'a jamais vu de tels
retards et on avait répondu à monsieur
anoh que tout allait aller mieux tout le
monde allait s'y mettre et que tout
allait être réglé or actuellement la
moitié de mes dossiers que j'ai transmis
en mai et en juin c'est à dire il ya
plus de quatre mois ne sont toujours pas
traitées alors il ne faut pas croire que
c'est quelque chose d'anodin car les
communes sont bloqués et ne peuvent pas
réaliser engager les travaux on se
rapproche de l'hiver et dans les
départements du nord ou de l'est de la
france
tout le monde sait qu'on ne peut pas
faire de travaux publics en hiver au
niveau des fins des problèmes
météorologiques
alors moi je ne comprends pas je ne
comprends je ne comprends vraiment pas
en trente ans de vie parlementaire
j'ai jamais vu des délais tels que ceux
qu'ont actuellement alors je veux bien
excipit y ait pu y avoir des problèmes
mais si on alerte si le président anoh a
alerté en disant ça va pas il ya des
choses qui vont pas et que le système
continue comme avant
eh bien je considère que c'est pas
normal alors moi on m'a dit bah ouais
mais il suffit de nous le dire
alors s'il suffit que tel ou tel
sénateur plus ou moins introduit puisse
intervenir pour obtenir tel ou tel
avancement de dossier mais que les
autres qui soit parce que disons ils
sont pas intervenus spécifiquement ou
soit qu'ils ont pas les mêmes
introduction ben disons leur dossier
continue à traîner
je considère que c'est pas normal et
quatre mois
plus de quatre mois pour gérer les
dossiers qui sont de l'avis même des
fonctionnaires concernés des dossiers
complets à jour et donc qui aurait pu
être l'objet d'une signature dans les
quinze jours
eh bien
c'est tout à fait anormal on va des
crédits on vote des lignes budgétaires
je trouve que le gouvernement devrait
faire son travail et dans cette
affaire-là le gouvernement ne fait pas
son travail et il serait opportun que le
gouvernement soit vraiment alerté le
dossier que nous avons tout à l'heure
concerne les collectivités territoriales
ça tombe bien ça concerne indirectement
la réserve parlementaire et je
souhaitais que le représentant du
gouvernement qui siège dans cette
enceinte essaye de faire de faire ce
qu'il peut et en fait non pas de faire
si peu mais de faire son travail a pour
que les choses soient rectifiées merci
chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur jean claude
lenoir pour un rappel au règlement bien
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je voudrais d'abord partagé à
l'avant ce monsieur le président votre
avis qui est que ces rappels au
règlement ne prennent évidemment pas sur
les quatre heures réservées à la
discussion de la proposition de loi de
notre collègue eric doligé mon
intervention se fonde sur l'article que
vous avez tous en mémoire du règlement
concernant l'organisation de nos travaux
le cafouillage ajoute aux cafouillages
et la confusion s'ajoute à la confusion
hier soir et cette journée aura été
vraiment une mauvaise journée cette
semaine une très mauvaise journée pour
le gouvernement d'ailleurs je note que
24 octobre était dans le calendrier
révolutionnaire le troisième jour de
brumaire c'est à dire officiellement le
jour de la poire et mauvaise journée
parce que hier soir la commission des
affaires économiques a voté une
exception d'irrecevabilité présenté par
nos collègues communistes
concernant la proposition de loi sur la
tarification provisoire progressi
pardonnez-moi provisoire peut-être de
l'électricité du gaz et de l'eau devenu
une loi de transition énergétique
cette exception d'irrecevabilité a été
votée parce que ce texte a été mis en
discussion dans la plus grande confusion
un teg lui est arrivé l'assemblée
nationale qui manifestement n'en portait
pas la conviction de nos collègues
socialistes et c'est la veille au soir
que nous avons une nouvelle rédaction
qui a été mise sous notre nez au moment
où nous nous réunissions dans la
commission des affaires
no milk il n'est pas admissible que sur
un texte qui a été déposée au début du
mois septembre mis sur les rails à
l'assemblée nationale fin septembre
déclaré d'urgence par le gouvernement et
nous sommes fin octobre nous ayons ainsi
une rédaction qui soit changeantes et
qui nous permettent pas de délibéré mais
le plus important c'est que hier soir
madame delphine batho ministre en charge
de l'énergie s'est autorisée a déclaré
qu'elle trouvait d'indicible que les
sénateurs communistes et mélanger leurs
voix à celles de groupes ump et du
centre je voudrais dire ici d'abord
rendons à césar ce qui est à césar c'est
la droite et le centre qui ont joint
leurs voix à celles des sénateurs
communistes mais le plus important
monsieur le président c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de pestiférés dans cette assemblée
il n'est pas interdit à des
parlementaires de partager les mêmes
convictions de défendre les mêmes
valeurs et de s'opposer à des textes
mauvais je demande monsieur le président
que la remarque soit faite à madame la
ministre en charge de l'énergie
merci chers collègues et naturellement
je confirme que le le temps du débat
commencera après ses rappels au
règlement
j'ai une demande de rappel règlement de
monsieur didier guillaume assez monsieur
le président mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues pour un rappel au
règlement dans le langage populaire on
aurait dit c'est un éléphant dans un
magasin de porcelaine
puisque je considère que les rappels au
règlement que vous faites concernant ce
qu'est l'interview du premier ministre
ce matin est quelque chose de solder le
premier ministre ya une dépêche un
communiqué de matignon en disant que ça
avait été mal compris il a bien prononcé
ces phrases mais en même temps en même
temps quand j'entends tout à l'heure par
l'one nos collègues évoqué que le
conseil constitutionnel si il re toqué
le texte serait pour un cafouillage
parlementaire mais de quoi s'agit-il
est ce que certains auraient plus
d'informations que d'autres on ne sait
pas ce qui va se passer et donc pas pu
si le texte était retoqué si le texte
était retoqué si le terrain geert ok pas
plus pas plus le motive je vous en prie
si le légères qui ont été retoqués pas
plus le motif que cela et le président
de le premier ministre a retiré en
partie ce qu'il avait dit à l'heure mais
je veux venir maintenant mais oui mais
vous êtes seul à cela cela montre bien
peut-être cela montre bien que vous avez
d'autre dessein que ceux pour lesquels
vous avez peut-être fait votre appel au
règlement je n'en suis pas sûr mais cela
peut être le cas alors j'en viens j'en
viens au fond sur les sujets que qui on
est et qui ont été évoqués sur le
logement
moi je suis désolé mais chers collègues
quand j'entends dire par un nos
collègues présidents de groupe que la
loi sur le logement et de l'affichage
politique
je voulais simplement vous dire que pour
des milliers de nos concitoyens
le logement c'est pas de l'affichage
politique c'est une nécessité parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de logement ou tout
simplement ils ont des villes vivent
dans des passoires énergétiques et ça
c'est important
et voilà pourquoi il y avait urgence que
cette loi sur le logement soit soit
votée et quand madame létard pas de
nouveau délai ben on en est désolé mais
s'il fallait aller si vite dans la loi
sur le logement
peut-être que nous aurions pu être plus
nombreux à voter cette loi sur le sur le
logement sur la transition énergétique
sur la transition énergétique
nous étions quelques-uns hier en
commission lorsqu'il ya eu ce débat
la démocratie s'est exprimée une
majorité dans la commission a voté pour
la motion de redire seul habilité
la commission s'est arrêtée peu importe
et on dit on va perdre encore de temps
mais moi je sens je tiens simplement à
dire une chose la loi était peut-être
mal écrite comme ça a été dit je n'en
sais rien mais ce que je constate c'est
que dans un mois il y aura l'hiver et
qui a beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui
aurait été heureux d'avoir le bonus
malus et des tarifs progressifs de
l'électricité parce que c'est sont ces
gens là qui s'ouvre et qui aujourd'hui
n'ont pas forcément les moyens et sur le
troisième sujet
sur le troisième sujet qui est celui des
normes et là je pense que nous pouvons
nous retrouver assez facilement
non madame 3 les trente amendements ce
n'est pas de l'obstruction 30
amendements
c'est aussi la volonté d'avancer mais
vous savez très bien aussi que sur
d'autres ou 48 ans rien que sur d'autres
sujets nous avons la possibilité de nous
retrouver
car monsieur christophe béchu déposent
une proposition de loi qui reprise par
l'ensemble de notre assemblée
nous nous retrouvons parce que cette
proposition de loi est bonne et sur la
ppl de monsieur doligé je vous rappelle
aussi que le président du sénat a pris
des initiatives
il l'a évoqué à plusieurs reprises
notamment au dernier bureau et que sous
l'égide du à la demande du président du
sénat sous l'égide de la présidente
bourreau de la côte délégation aux
collectivités territoriales et bien des
textes vont être mises en oeuvre sur le
statut de l'élu est également sur les
normes en essayant que ces textes soient
le plus largement possible accepté sur
ces sujets là il s'agit pas de faire de
l'opposition veine il s'agit de trouver
combien les élus locaux pour les pour le
statut de l'élu pourrait se retrouver
comme pour les normes et je pense que
sur ces sujets il n'y a pas les vertus
et les autres il n'ya pas ceux qui
défendent mieux les territoires et les
autres nous essayons tout et tous
d'avancer dans la meilleure direction
possible en tout cas le groupe
socialiste sur le logement comme sur les
normes comme sous la transition
énergétique votera les textes qu'ils
iront dans le sens du bien être de nos
concitoyens et de ce que veulent les
élus aux états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale les élus les 21000 élus qui
se sont exprimées par sondages par
enquête
ceux qui sont venus aussi le vendredi
malheureusement nous n'y étions pas tous
mais c'était important ce vendredi entre
exprimer des choses assez forte qu'il
soit enfin entendu que ce qui est évoqué
depuis des décennies sur le statut de
l'élu et les normes soient enfin 2 me
sur la table et je crois que nous y
arriverons donc les rappels au règlement
hantée ont été faits nous entendons sur
certains sujets nous avons aussi nous
des interrogations vous le savez très
bien mais en tout cas je vais vous dire
que le groupe socialiste a la ferme
volonté c'est que le sénat soit
respectée et que le sénat puisse
débattre dans la tranquillité possible
les lois qui vont dans le meilleur sens
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur hervé maurey
pour un rappel au règlement
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
les miss mes chers collègues je ne
reviendrai pas sur les épisodes tout à
fait lamentable dans lesquelles ont été
adoptée la loi duflot ni sur les
conditions rocambolesques de la prise de
parole du premier ministre ce matin cela
était largement et très bien évoqué par
mes collègues et dans un ghetto et
valérie létard moi je voudrais faire un
rappel au règlement sur la base de
l'article 44
concernant l'organisation de nos travaux
et le fait que nous ayons reçu quelques
minutes avant la séance une motion de
renvoi en commission concernant la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
doligé que nous devons examiner
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
le fait que cette demande de renvoi en
commission me paraît contraire
et elle est contraire à l'article 44 de
notre règlement qui dit qu'une demande
de renvoi en commission n'est pas
recevable
sauf demande de renvoi est maintenant du
gouvernement de la commission saisie au
fond lorsque un vote est déjà intervenu
sur une demande de renvoi
et c'est ce qui c'est c'est le cas en
l'espèce puisqu'il ya déjà eu le 15
février une demande de renvoi en
commission et un renvoi en commission
qui ont été adaptés adopter pour ce
texte
donc nous y voyons une manoeuvre
supplémentaires pour enterrer ce texte
qui a il faut bien l'avouer un défaut
considérable aux yeux de la majorité
c'est qu'ils émanent d'un parlementaire
de l'opposition est donc tout est fait
depuis l'origine pour enterrer ce texte
on l'a renvoyé en commission mois de
février après en commission n'a fait en
sorte de le vider en grande partie de sa
substance
et puis aujourd'hui on ne donne que
quatre heures daudet de débats en
refusant d'ouvrir la nuit
et puis on découvre qu'il y à cet
orateur de la discussion générale avant
même les représentants des groupes
politiques ce qui est tout à fait
exceptionnelle et enfin au dernier
moment on sort une nouvelle demande de
renvoi en commission
je crois que cela n'ait n'est pas
tolérable et on voit bien dans les
propos qui viennent d'être tenus qu'en
fait ce qu'on veut c'est enterrer le
texte pour sortir un texte dont la
gauche
pourra proclamer avoir la paternité donc
c'est très bien quand le président de la
république exprime la nécessité de
combattre l'inflation des normes mais ce
qui est dommage c'est que dans les faits
on observe que la majorité a la volonté
d'enterrer ce texte
merci chers collègues la parole est à
jean vincent placé pour un rappel au
règlement
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues - quand je suis arrivé ici on
m'avait dit c'est une assemblée de sages
de notables de gens qui attachés au
bicamérisme essaye d'élever la pensée
politique et d'essayer d'amendé et puis
nous voilà en plein congrès de l'ump
avec une mobilisation massive sur les
bancs de l'opposition sénatoriale
extrêmement ravis de ce qu'ils sont pas
je vous le dis ddd cafouillage parce
qu'effectivement ce terme je les assume
de le dire est impropre
il n'y a pas eu de cafouillage
parlementaire sommes bien sûr il n'y a
pas eu de cafouillage parlementaire il
ya eu l'exercice comme dans toute
démocratie des pouvoirs par les uns et
les autres
le gouvernement a décidé de faire une
convocation d'une session extraordinaire
anticipé nous à la conférence des
présidents
nous avons dit ce qu'il y avait à dire
la commission s'est réunie le texte de
loi a été présenté et il y a eu
d'ailleurs de très belles interventions
sur les motions de procédure et je tiens
à saluer là dessus roger karoutchi
parce que forcément là dessus il était
très expert parce que il raconte
exactement le contraire quand il était
ministre des relations avec le parlement
ainsi que son successeur monsieur de
raincourt
parce que à force d'avoir le parlement
godillot sous sarkozy
vous étiez extrêmement entraîné pour
connaître les arguments du procureur et
de la défense
voilà les réalités
après le conseil constitutionnel va dire
des choses tout à l'heure le conseil
constitutionnel va dire des choses tout
à l'heure et quand elles seront dit eh
bien cela s'appliquera à toutes et tous
je ne crois pas que le président de la
république française d'aujourd'hui dira
comme le présent la république française
après le débat sur l'arménie en disant
moi je m'en fous du conseil
constitutionnel je re fresnoy non mais
nous ce qui va se passer c'est con oui
mais dans les délais avec la procédure
en tenons compte en tenant côte mais et
alors et alors mais qu'y at il de
choquant de faire ce parcours là parce
que si vous vous êtes des passionnés la
vème république
vous voulez le culte bonapartiste de
tout ce qui passe de l'elysée et tout le
monde veille mais si c'est le ça la
réalité et nous nous voulons faire vivre
le parlement nous voulons travailler
autrement et y compris le fait que des
groupes de la majorité disent leur avis
et expriment des votes différents
alors évidemment il faut pas le faire
toujours parce que sinon ça ne rime plus
à grand chose et c'est moi qui le dit et
bien c'est sain pour la démocratie
ce qu'ont fait nos amis communistes
c'est une attention sociales par rapport
à question de la tarification énergie je
suis sûr que le gouvernement va être
attentif
donc nous nous avons à faire quelque
chose d'intelligent pour notre haute
assemblée c'est revaloriser le rôle du
parlement et donné une bonne image et
parlementaires à l'extérieur donc c'est
bien normal que l'opposition s'oppose
c'est normal aussi que les groupes
appartenant à la majorité sénatoriale et
qui ne sont pas le groupe majoritaire
expriment de temps en temps des
divergences de temps en temps des
objections et souvent du soutien et
c'est normal aussi que le groupe
socialiste soit le fidèle piliers de ce
gouvernement
chacun est dans son rôle et c'est ça la
démocratie et moi c'est ça que je
souhaite pour notre haute assemblée
qu'on puisse discuter se respecter et
pas donné ce simulacre ridicule de
théâtre que vous voulez nous infliger ce
soir je vous remercie
bon
très bien mes chers collègues monsieur
le président de la commission monsieur
le président mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention tout ce qui a été
dit et je crois en effet qu'il est
important et cela a été dit à la
conférence des présidents par les uns et
les autres je le souligne d'être
attentif aux règles qui sont les nôtres
par rapport à la procédure parlementaire
s'agissant de la commission des lois
puis ce que j'interviens à ce titre il a
été dit par l'une des oratrices de
madame droehnlé qu'il y avait eu
beaucoup d'amendements venant d'un
groupe
je dois vous dire que sur le texte de
monsieur doligé qui est un texte
important
il y a eu trente amendements qui ont été
présentés je ne pense pas que ce soit
excessif par les groupes ump et union
centriste e32 par le groupe socialiste
3 par le gouvernement 1 par le rds e et
un parano inscrit donc il y a eu un
débat normal sur un texte important et
ce débat nous allons langage est ici en
science publique dans quelques instants
en second lieu il a été dit qu'il y
avait des orateurs inscrits avant les
orateurs des groupes
mes chers collègues il y à un rapporteur
au fond 3 rapporteur pour avis un
président de commission
une ministre c'est la règle
et cela vaut dans tous les textes il est
obligé de parler vous avez raison
monsieur s mais il peut le faire
vous en avez usé et donc nous sommes
dans nos règles et enfin par rapport aux
interprétations qui peuvent être données
de l'initiative prise par monsieur le
président du sénat à la suite des états
généraux
nous avons été chargés c'est un honneur
madame la présidente jacqueline gourault
et moi-même devrait pour tenter de
donner suite au travail très importante
qui a eu dans les états généraux lors
des états généraux
par ailleurs monsieur eric doligé a fait
un texte il a travaillé dans l'âme le
rapporteur a travaillé sur ce texte
je dirais simplement que comme l'a dit
un penseur du 20e siècle
tout ce qui monte converge et je
souhaiterais que la convergence des
efforts se fasse pour le plus grand bien
des collectivités locales et des élus
locaux je vous remercie
merci chers collègues merci monsieur le
président
et bien je vous propose de commencer à
décompter le temps à partir de
maintenant l'ordre du jour appelle donc
la discussion de la proposition de loi
de simplification des normes applicables
aux collectivités locales présentée par
monsieur eric doligé dans la discussion
générale
la parole est à monsieur eric doligé ump
auteur de la proposition de loi
sur le président mesdames les ministres
monsieur le président de la commission
madame la présidente rapporteur chers
collègues baisser les dépenses publiques
est un besoin vital pour notre société
nous avons mis beaucoup de temps pour en
prendre conscience et pourtant dès les
années 1990
nombre de pays avaient déjà pris des
décisions courageuses en réformant
profondément leur organisation
territoriale et celle de leurs
administrations mais aussi en acceptant
des remises en causes structurelles
ainsi le canada certains pays d'europe
du nord comme la suède la finlande ou
encore le danemark n'ont pas hésité à
tailler dans leurs dépenses
administratives et à réduire la voilure
les études sur l'évolution de ces
différents pays montrent clairement que
leurs déficits a largement régressé et
qu'ils connaissent même des excédents
pour autant ils n'ont pas casser la
croissance et pénaliser l'emploi le
monde des entreprises a compris depuis
fort longtemps que pour être compétitif
il faut abaisser les coûts et produire
sans entraves superflu parallèlement
l'état continue à produire des
contraintes et des charges nouvelles qui
n'est en mesure de compenser que par des
taxes et des impôts nouveaux
conduisant en retour à une perte de
compétitivité amplifié de plus il a une
fâcheuse tendance à mettre au banc des
accusés
les chefs d'entreprise créateur de
richesses nous voyons chaque jour les
dégâts que génère dans l'industrie la
mise en cause des grands groupes nous en
constatons l'inefficacité sur le
redressement
lorsque le président de la république
nicolas sarkozy a décidé un moratoire
sur toutes les normes applicables aux
collectivités locales et qu'il a nommé
un commissaire à la simplification
j'ai compris que nous prenions enfin la
bonne direction celle du parti de la
compétitivité moins d'entravés de la
part de la sphère publique
c'est plus de souplesse pour notre
économie en janvier 2011 le président
m'a demandé qu'en prenant en
considération les propositions formulées
par les principales associations d'élus
je propose des mesures de simplification
ambitieuses et concrètes pour desserrer
les contraintes et alléger les coûts
excessifs qui pèsent sur les
collectivités territoriales
en m'attachant à identifier les normes
qui doivent être prioritairement modifié
en raison de leur caractère inadapté et
coûteux
l'objectif étant de rendre notre cadre
juridique plus propice à l'initiative et
à l'investissement public durant quatre
mois j'ai pu ainsi auditionné les
présidents des associations d'élus
les responsables de nombreux syndicats
et l'ensemble des ministères produisant
des normes
tous ont clairement dit quelle que soit
leur sensibilité que les normes était un
frein à la compétitivité une source de
complexité voire une perte de temps et
naturellement un générateur de coût
supplémentaire pour nos collectivités
coup systématiquement répercutées sur
les citoyens et l'économie dans un
contexte financier difficile où les
collectivités locales exerce de
nombreuses prérogatives
autrefois dévolues à l'état la
prolifération normative incarne la
fracture entre d'un côté un état central
prescripteurs de dépenses et de
contraintes nouvelles et de l'autre des
collectivités locales devant sans cesse
mobiliser des crédits nouveaux pour
financer les dispositifs pensé et conçu
au plan national face à l'empilement des
textes
la perspective d'une simplification
fédère l'ensemble des acteurs locaux
ils aspirent tous à une évolution du
mode de gouvernance afin que les
problèmes quotidiens que rencontrent les
collectivités locales dans l'application
des normes soient durablement prise en
compte de ces multiples échanges j'ai pu
ressortir 20 grands principes je n'en
citerai que certains pas de réforme de
collectivités locales sans évaluation
préalable partager des politiques
locales qui sera intéressant de voir
comment seront pris en compte les
propositions faites durant les états
généraux des et pas de nouveaux textes
réglementaires sans une évaluation
réaliste et un avis motivé de la ccn
l'objectif étant d'imposer la sincérité
de l'évaluation des coûts de l'ensemble
des textes dans la ccrl nous constatons
actuellement que la fourchette des
évaluations fournies par les services de
l'état est souvent fort loin de la
réalité
donner une véritable place aux
collectivités locales dans l'élaboration
de la réglementation européenne mais
également ne pas ajouter nos normes
franco française
on en europe et n nous pénalisons un peu
plus dans la course à la compétitivité
réduire l'instabilité juridique
organisée le reflux normatif le
président de la république vient de
demander sous différents ministères de
s'attaquer aux normes mais aussi de
supprimer une norme lorsqu'on l'encré
pallier l'absence de décret
d'application
bruno sido exposait encore lundi au
président de la république que nous
attendions que des décrets près pareil
sur les possibilités de rapprochement
des services d'esquisser des conseils
généraux adapter les normes à la taille
des collectivités c'est l'adaptabilité
si chère au président de la république
et au président du sénat est l'objet de
l'article 1er faire face aux manques
d'ingénierie publique suite à la
disparition de nombreux services
déconcentrés de l'état au travers de 262
propositions pour simplifier le droit
applicable collectivités qui résulte des
diverses auditions il est ressorti que
la simplification et est urgente face à
l'engrenage normative qui entravent
l'action des collectivités territoriales
en procédant un changement de la
gouvernance normative entre l'état et
les collectivités locales
l'allègement des contraintes des
collectivités face aux normes rigide et
coûteuse est une nécessité en changer en
profondeur la culture normatif de l'état
et en imposant une obligation de
résultat plutôt que de moyens à ce titre
j'ai proposé en prod2 limité à 15 le
nombre de ministères je constate que les
candidats à la présidence de la
république se fit souvent un objectif
proche mais n'arrive jamais à le mettre
en oeuvre
j'ajouterai à titre personnel que je
suis intimement persuadé qu'il faut
également avoir le courage de réduire
très sensiblement le nombre de
parlementaires
cela mériterait un vrai débat au moment
de la discussion sur le cumul
j'ai remis ce rapport sur la
simplification des normes au président
nicolas sarkozy en juin 2011 et est
déposée la ppl le 4 août 2011
le président gérard larcher alors
président du sénat persuadé de
l'importance de ce texte pour le bon
fonctionnement de nos collectivités a
saisi le conseil d'état
une première pour le sénat j'ai été
auditionné par le conseil d'état début
2011 le processus a été interrompu suite
au changement de majorité au sénat le
président jean pierre bel persuadé
également sur le pense de la serre est
l'intérêt de ce texte a relancé le
processus est demandé au conseil d'état
de bien vouloir lui remettre son rapport
la ppl comme chacun le sait a été étudié
en séance au sénat le 15 février 2012
la proximité des élections
présidentielle et législatives a
probablement eu une influence sur le
débat en définitive il a été décidé en
février 2012
il y a huit mois un renvoi en commission
cette nouvelle présentation
d'aujourd'hui fait suite à ce renvoi je
pense où j'espérais quand lui mois la
commission a pu se faire une idée et se
positionner sur chacun des articles
a priori cela n'a pas été le cas pour
l'article 1 pour lequel la commission
n'a pas encore été en mesure de proposer
une rédaction
j'ai cru comprendre aussi que nos
collègues communistes allaient reproché
de ne pas avoir mis ses huit mois en
oeuvre pour permettre d'aller plus au
fond sur ce texte fin 2011
le président jean pierre bel a décidé
d'organiser les états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale comme chacun le
sait lors de ces différentes étapes
enquête réunions départementales et
réunion des 4 et 5 octobre dernier à
paris
les normes ont été au centre des
préoccupations des élus le président de
la république françois hollande s'est
largement exprimé sur le sujet et
inciter à plus de dix reprises le terme
des normes dans son discours il a
clairement plaidé pour la simplification
des normes
je reprends certaines de ses
interventions la confiance s'est enfin
l'allègement des normes dit il j'ai
compris que c'était une des
préoccupations sortie de vos états
généraux ou encore mais nous ne pouvons
plus accepter cette situation en termes
de coût pour les collectivités en termes
de délais pour les procédures cela le
disent et il en parlant des normes
le président du sénat jean-pierre bel
s'est également largement exprimé sur le
sujet dans le journal la république du
sang du 4 octobre 2012 que vous lisez
peut-être pas tous mais que
le président de la commission des lois
lee il annonçait au sujet des deux
journées des états généraux nous allons
faire ressortir le point de vue des élus
sur la simplification des normes
nos territoires sont divers or on fait
des lois qui doivent s'appliquer partout
comme si toutes les situations étaient
les mêmes partout
la notion d'adaptation dans
l'application des lois est essentielle
donc je ne faisait que citer le
président blaise ainsi les deux
présidents de la république successifs
les deux présidents du sénat et les deux
premiers ministres qui se sont succédé
ont tous la conviction que la
simplification des normes est un élément
essentiel dans le cadre du
fonctionnement de nos collectivités
nous sommes là dans une continuité
parfaite le point central qui a été
abordé par tous les élus par les plus
hauts responsables de l'état et celui de
l'adaptabilité
tous sont convaincus qu'il est
nécessaire d'adapter les normes aux
territoires
vous connaissez tous la ppl que nous
allons étudier aujourd'hui son article 1
vise ainsi à introduire dans notre droit
positif le principal pour nationalité
des normes et celui de leur adaptation à
la taille des collectivités
suite au rapport du conseil d'état j'ai
pris en compte toutes ces remarques et
proposé un amendement à l'article 1er de
la ppl que j'ai déposé il al'avantage de
donner satisfaction aux orientations
définies par le président de la
république dans le premier ministre et
par le président du sénat j'ai bien vu
de la première discussion février 2012
que cette proposition n'avait pas l'air
de plaire à la majorité du sénat qui
n'avait pas encore la majorité à tous
les niveaux et je constate que cette
orientation de l'adaptabilité n'est pas
encore totalement intégrés au parlement
bien qu'elle le soit au plus haut niveau
de l'état
je pense qu'il faudra être patient ce
qui ne m'empêche pas de redéposer un
amendement celui qui avait présenté
madame gouro que je trouve tout à fait
compatible avec ma conviction sur le
sujet de l'adopter ce serait donner
ainsi nos élus qu'ils attendent avec
impatience ne les avez vous pas entendu
lors des états généraux réclamé à
l'unisson la simplification des normes
je me permets à cet instant de citer une
partie de l'avis du conseil d'état sur
l'adaptabilité
je voudrais aussi rassuré
monsieur alain richard mais aussi le
groupe communiste cet avis n'est pas une
propriété d'éric doligé comme ils l'ont
dit ou comme monsieur richard l'a dit il
appartient au président du sénat d'en
disposer
pour ma part ayant pu en avoir copie
gelé mis à disposition de ceux qui me
l'ont demandé
cet avis nous dit concernant cet article
1er en vue de poursuivre l'objectif
justifier de remédier aux contraintes
entraîné pour de nombreuses
collectivités par l'application de
mesures réglementaires dont la
multiplication est un sujet légitime de
préoccupation
il appartient au législateur de prévoir
des adaptations tenant compte notamment
de la situation des collectivités
territoriales de faibles capacités
financières je fais confiance à la
majorité pour reprendre à son compte cet
article 1er dans ce texte
ou peut-être dans un prochain texte
cette orientation est irréversible
j'avais également évoqué dans mon
rapport la difficulté que nous aurions à
atteindre les objectifs de délais que le
parlement s'est fixé généreusement dans
diverses lois de manière que l'on
pourrait qualifier à responsabilité
limitée il s'agit de deux sujets
délicats celui des normes
environnementales et de l'accessibilité
c'est là le sujet d'inquiétude numéro 1
soulevées par les élus ils sont tous
conscients que pour des questions de
coût et technique
ils ne seront pas au rendez vous des
dates fixées par nos lois
ce lundi 24 octobre lors de la réception
des représentants des conseils généraux
le président de la république a précisé
alors que j'avais évoqué devant lui les
normes sur les normes
il faudra que nous ayons une discussion
franche avec les associations sur le
handicap l'assainissement
l'environnement le calendrier est
impossible madame la ministre vous étiez
présente toutes les deux à cette réunion
je pense que les débats risquent d'être
tendues sur ces sujets lorsqu'il fera ni
nécessairement l'airé abords de l'airé
abordés mesdames et messieurs de la
majorité ça sera à vous de relancer
cette problématique les articles
suivants de la ppl relatives à la ccn et
la cerfres s ont fait l'objet
d'amendements intéressant je vais
regrette toutefois que l'idée d'une
commission consultative départementale
d'application des normes n'est pas été
comprise son but n'était certes pas de
créer une commission supplémentaire qui
apporterait des contraintes nouvelles
mais d'avoir une structure fait
d'anciens élus je pense qu'avec la loi
sur le non-cumul
beaucoup vont être disponibles il
pourrait aider les mères en exercice à
défendre par cet intermédiaire neutre
leurs difficultés d'application de
certaines normes inadaptés à leur
territoire
il avait là un rôle de médiation entre
les collectivités et les services
déconcentrés de l'état sur le
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales de très nombreux articles
de la ppl ont été adoptées avec quelques
modifications
l'article 18 sur les ccas a fait débat
lors d'une discussion il ya quelques
mois j'avais précisé que je n'étais pas
opposé à ce que l'on établisse un seuil
au-delà duquel les crs seraient
obligatoires a contrario en dessous il
pouvait y avoir faculté de faire un
choix
ce seuil a été proposée par amendement à
15 cents habitants la proposition est
intéressante
je crois même qu une obligation de
création d'assez y as a été proposée
pour les intercommunalités
le titre iii et relatifs à l'urbanisme
et l'aménagement
la commission a proposé de supprimer la
plupart des articles je peux comprendre
vos interrogations face à un vrai sujet
et je reprendrai la phrase de patrice
gélard en commission des dispositions
mal écrite est inadaptable donne lieu à
des procédures interminables devant les
tribunaux administratifs ce que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui sur beaucoup de
sujets concernant ses problèmes
d'urbanisme et d'aménagement
il me paraît important d'y revenir plus
tard le président de la république a
précisé ce lundi que tous les ministères
ont été saisis et doivent proposer des
simplifications de normes
je peux vous confirmer que j'ai déjà
fait ce travail avec les ministères il y
a quelques mois et que les propositions
qui vous sont soumises et été vue est
passé au peigne fin avec tous les
ministères concernés
il me semblerait surprenant que l'on
arrive à des propositions différentes
uniquement parce que la majorité a
changé
ce ne sont pas des problèmes politiques
mais des problèmes pragmatique un
article le 27 qui me tenait à coeur
avait trait à l'arc et
j préventive il consistait à encadrer la
signature de la convention afin de
limiter les dérapages et tout ce que
cela peut entraîner
j'ai vu que vous aviez supprimer cet
article
au motif que le ministère de la culture
préparer un nouveau texte sur
l'archéologie préventive
je vous dis que je crains le pire en la
matière j'ai vécu comme certains d'entre
vous plusieurs réformes sur le sujet qui
avait pour but de simplifier et
d'alléger les coûts résultat à chaque
fois cela a conduit à plus de complexité
à des augmentations de charges sous la
pression des professionnels
cela est dû cela est devenu
insupportable à tel point que c'est dans
la hiérarchie des problèmes
l'un des plus importantes nous
constatons avant de pouvoir accueillir
une entreprise des coûts qui atteignent
régulièrement un voire plusieurs
millions d'euros dans ces conditions il
ne faut pas s'étonner de constater que
des entreprises passent leur chemin et à
s'implanter dans des pays plus
accueillants où les surcoûts ne sont pas
aussi importants et où les délais sont
compatibles avec les exigences de
l'entreprise
pensez vous que dans une société en
grande difficulté nous puissions
toujours nous permettre d'investir des
montants de plusieurs millions d'euros
sur une opération de fouille avec des
délais longs alors que l'on sait à
l'avancé que l'on va découvrir
n'y at il pas des priorités à définir et
à mieux cerner sur ce sujet pour
terminer cette ppl
j'ai souhaité proposer la fusion de deux
réseaux intervenant dans le dépistage et
la luttre quand les contre les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
et les centres d'information de
dépistage et de diagnostic des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
le conseil d'état a précisé que cette
mesure de simplification ne soulevait
pas elle-même de difficulté de principe
j'avais prévu pour diverses raisons de
retirer cet article 33
il n'est pas dit que je le retire pas en
fonction de l'heure à laquelle nous
serons quand on arrivera à l'article 30
points
l'avis positif sur cette fusion rendu à
l'unanimité par le conseil national du
sida du sida sur la fusion des centres
de dépistage et diagnostic du vih et des
ist et publié le 5 octobre 2012
mme avec moi convaincu de réintroduire
cet art je souhaite que nous puissions
dépasser sur ce dossier
de la simplification des normes les
clivages politiques habituels au cours
des six derniers mois
chacun a pu constater qu'à tous les
niveaux de l'état et que tous les élus
souhaitaient avancer rapidement et enfin
voir traiter ce dossier des normes le 10
octobre 2012 le président jean pierre
bel a demandé à notre haute assemblée de
préparer une ppl sur la simplification
des normes dans la foulée les états
généraux de la démocratie locale
j'ai le plaisir de vous proposer cette
ppl ce qui devrait faire gagner beaucoup
de temps et surtout permettra de rendre
irréversible cette marche vers la
simplification des normes
j'ajouterai pour conclure que 65
amendements ont été proposés
j'ai bien retenu les chiffres de
monsieur sueur jouer avoue aussi que les
analyses et les uns après les autres il
y en a des plus courts que les autres je
m'interroge quand à certains de ceux ci
tels la douzaine qui a été déposé après
l'article 18 qui ont principalement
trait à l'hébergement des personnes
âgées
cela ressemble à des cavaliers il montre
certes la nécessité de simplifier en
tous domaines
mais à eux seuls ils mériteraient une
loi spécifique peut-être sur la
dépendance
j'espère simplement que ces amendements
non pas comme seul but n'ont comme seul
but que d'enrichir le texte et non de
l'empêcher d'arriver à son terme
aujourd'hui
voilà chers collègues que je souhaitais
vous dire sur ce sujet qui théoriquement
vous intéresse tous jusqu'au niveau du
chef de l'état merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à madame
jacqueline roux bourreau rapporteur de
la commission des lois
ça vas y tu vas bien
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
monsieur le sénateur doligé mes chers
collègues je ne reviens pas sur toute la
procédure que eric doligé vient de
rappeler leurs voix en commission etc
on va reprendre les choses maintenant au
jour où nous sommes bien sûr nous sommes
chars eric doligé complètement d'accord
avec vous sur la nécessité de rappeler
les méfaits je dirais à ces terribles
des normes dans la vie quotidienne des
élus et je dirais pour le budget aussi
des collectivités territoriales et donc
c'est une préoccupation comme vous
l'avez dit vous-même transversale dans
le sens où quelle que soit l'étiquette
des élus eh bien naturellement ils
subissent le même sort je dirais à
propos des de l'inflation normatif
d'ailleurs pour la période récente la
délégation collectivités territoriales
et à la décentralisation qui était alors
sous la houlette de notre collègue
claude belot avec identifier en 2011 les
secteurs les plus touchés par la
production réglementaire avec l'aide des
commissions permanentes de notre
assemblée
plus récemment et vous l'avez rappelé
tout à l'heure ce phénomène d'inflation
a été une des préoccupations majeures
des états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale organisé en octobre dernier
par le président du sénat c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raison
effectivement que le président du sénat
a demandé à ce qu'on se penche sur ce
sujet avec celui d'ailleurs du statut de
l'élu
pour répondre aux attentes de nombreux
élus des collectivités territoriales et
puis il y à votre initiative eric doligé
qui est présenté aujourd'hui pour
desserrer l'étau normatif des
collectivités territoriales c'est
naturellement un premier pas au terme de
l'examen de la proposition de loi
la commission des lois a choisi
d'appuyer le dispositif de
simplification sur les outils existants
dont elle a pu mesurer les vertus et les
insuffisances pour le reste elle a
écarté des mesures qui ne le semblait
pas s'inscrire dans le processus
d'allégement des propositions qu'ils
n'avaient aucun lien avec la proposition
de loi ou des aspects des propositions
aussi qui ne lui apparaissait pas
juridiquement je dirais sécurisé je
précise que la commission des lois a
délégué aux commissions saisies pour
avis l'examen des articles relevant de
leurs seules compétences alors au
préalable il y a eu bien sûr la
commission a supprimé l'article 1er
introduisant dans le code général des
collectivités territoriales un principe
de proportionnalité des normes et de
leur adaptation à la situation des
collectivités
alors je voudrais m'arrêter un instant
sur ce sujet puisque c'est très
important et que eric doligé l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure en effet ce principe de
proportionnalité des normes
tout le monde est d'accord le problème
c'est comment le mettre en musique
si je puis dire et il est vrai que le
conseil constitutionnel a donné son avis
mais il a précisé n'est ce pas que cette
ce principe de proportionnalité des
normes ne pouvait pas être énoncé de
manière je dirais générale et
universelle que la proportionnalité des
normes ne pouvait pas donc faire l'objet
d'un principe dans une loi sinon c'est
inconstitutionnel
cela veut dire que la pro
portio nalité des lois doit être traité
au cas par cas
c'est à dire qu'il convient au pouvoir
prescripteur par exemple parlement une
mode yanis une modulation des règles
qu'il fixe dans la loi dans le respect
du principe d'égalité
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle aussi
bien votre texte mon amendement que la
proposition de loi de monsieur morel à
l'huissier à l'assemblée nationale a été
rejetée je dirais par ce simple fait que
la la le principe général ne peut pas
être votée
constitutionnellement pour renforcer le
contrôle des normes par ailleurs votre
commission a adopté plusieurs
amendements destinés à étendre les
compétences de la consultation compte de
la commission pardon consultative
d'évaluation des normes
ainsi afin que cette dernière soit
également compétente pour le stock de
normes car rappelons le sa compétence se
limite aujourd'hui uniquement aux flux
c'est à dire à la production des normes
nouvelles
la commission des lois a adopté le
principe d'un rapport annuel établi par
la commission consultative qui porterait
sur un secteur déterminé par celle ci ce
rapport serait l'occasion d'établir un
bilan des normes existence dans un
domaine particulier de recenser les
normes obsolètes ou inapplicables et de
présenter une série de propositions qui
lui serait remise au parlement et au
gouvernement
j'insiste qui serait remise au parlement
et au gouvernement pardon j'insiste sur
le terme remis et non transmis afin de
donner plus de solennité de publicité
aux conclusions de la commission son
président remettrai à l'instar du
premier président de la cour des comptes
son rapport aux deux assemblées et au
premier ministre
en revanche notre commission des lois
n'a pas étendu la compétence de la
commission règlement des fédérations
sportives
celles ci sont en effet déjà soumises au
contrôle de la commission d'examen des
règlements
fédéraux relatifs aux équipements
sportifs ce qui donne le sigle de serre
ferait ce dont l'activité est saluée par
les élus en charge du sport
l'existence de cette instance soulève
cependant trois observations
premièrement elle n'a pas d'existence
rome réglementaire deuxièmement les
représentants des élus locaux sont en
minorité au sein de cette commission
face aux représentants du monde sportif
troisièmement la commission ne dispose
que d'un délai de deux mois pour rendre
ses avis et pour faire face à ces
difficultés la commission des lois a
légalisé la commission au sein du code
général des collectivités territoriales
afin de renforcer l'existence de la
cerfres s et de la placer au même niveau
que la ccn chacune dans son domaine
ensuite elle a décidé d'attribuer aux
représentants des collectivités
territoriales
la moitié des sièges composant la
cerfres s enfin elle a doublé le du la
durée du délai qui lui est ouvert pour
rendre ses avis cette mesure dont fin
ces mesures devraient permettre
d'approfondir l'expertisé des normes qui
sont soumises par les par les sportifs
avec les fédérations sportives
de même votre commission des lois a
supprimé les articles 3 et 4 prévoyant
la création d'une console une commission
consultative départementale
d'application des normes et une
commission consultative des études
locales qui serait une nouvelle
formation restreinte du comité des
finances locales à l'instar de la ccn
dont je viens de parler
la suppression de des dispositifs des
dispositions relatives à ces deux
nouvelles instances a été guidé par le
souci de ne pas encombrer le paysage
institutionnel local
en effet combien de fois ne vont pas
entendu les élus locaux se plaindre de
la multiplication des instances locales
auxquelles ils ne peuvent assister
s'agissant de la commission consultative
des vies étude locale
l'émission qui lui auraient été confiées
peuvent être confiée à des commissions
déjà existantes comme la commission
consultative d'évaluation des charges
au delà de ce volet consacré à la
régulation normative la commission des
lois a approuvé les mesures destinées à
simplifier l'organisation et la gestion
des collectivités tout en encadrant et
complétant certaines d'entre elles dans
cette voie elle s'est attachée à
garantir l'accessibilité aux décisions
locales en conciliant le libre accès aux
actes administratifs pour tous et les
contraintes pesant sur les collectivités
ainsi elle a maintenu le principe de
l'exclusivité du support papier pour le
recueil des actes administratifs en
prévoyant toutefois pour alléger la
charge des collectivités que certains
d'entre eux déterminés par décret au
conseil d'état pour n'être publiées que
par voie électronique
si la commune optent pour la
dématérialisation de la publicité de ses
actes elle devra bien sûr toutefois
procédé à un affichage par extraits à la
porte de la mairie les syndicats mixtes
bénéficieront du même dispositif allégé
concernant les documents relatifs aux
délégations de services publics prévus
par les étapes pour les établissements
publics de coopération intercommunale
pour garantir l'obligation de
transmission des actes des collectivités
territoriales représentant de l'état
le compte de gestion sera envoyé par
voie dématérialisée par le directeur
départemental ou régional des finances
publiques à la demande non pas du préfet
mais de l'exécutif territorial pour
préserver le droit à l'information des
élus la commission a maintenu à 12 jours
le délai de transmission des rapports
aux membres des assemblées délibérantes
est institué à des les homologues de
cinq jours pour les dossiers à l'ordre
du jour de la commission permanente des
conseils généraux et régionaux
elle à harmoniser le régime d'adoption
du règlement intérieur en étendant le
principe proposer du mathier en vigueur
de l'ancien règlement du conseil général
jusqu'à l'adoption du nouveau document à
la suite du renouvellement général de
l'assemblée aux deux autres niveaux de
collectivités
c'est à dire les communes et les régions
s'interrogeant sur la capacité
technique et financière des petites et
moyennes communes d'organiser leur
concours de recrutement dans les
filières social médico-social et
médico-technique aujourd'hui de la
compétence des centres départementaux de
gestion
la commission a supprimé l'article 2 qui
leur ouvrait la faculté du procédé
elle a privilégié pour répondre aux
difficultés nées de la pério side
périodicité pardon des concours
la mutualisation par l'intermédiaire des
centres de gestion dans le prolongement
des modifications qu'elle a fait adopter
dans le cadre de la loi très récente du
12 mars 2012 sur la fonction publique et
nous avons donc considéré que ce n'était
pas la peine d'y revenir
s'agissant de la question de la
rationalisation des moyens des
collectivités
la commission a adopté une nouvelle
rédaction des articles l 123 ktl 123 5
du code de l'action sociale et des
familles afin de préciser de clarifier
les dispositions en matière de création
et de dissolution des centres communaux
d'action sociale et des centres
intercommunaux dassance d'action sociale
eric doligé l'a dit tout à l'heure nous
avons fixé à 1500 habitants la création
d'un ccas
je dirais obligatoire au dessus de 1500
habitants et que en dessous ce serait
bien sûr facultatif je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de ccas dans les
petites communes sont des coquilles
vides en matière d'urbanisme
plusieurs articles ont été supprimés en
raison des difficultés que leur mise en
oeuvre pourrait entraîner ou d'ailleurs
pourraient poser des questions
constitutionnelles par exemple la
création des secteurs de projet n'était
assortie d'aucune garantie solide
en effet la proposition de loi initial
prévoyait la possibilité pour les
préfets d'accorder des dérogations aux
règles fixées
je cite lorsque les caractéristiques de
l'opération projetée le nécessitait le
nécessitent et bien évidemment ce n'est
pas très précis et
c'est tout à fait même un précis de même
il apparaît risqué pour les mères que
soit autorisé la signature de promesse
de vente de location avant la délivrance
du permis d'aménager un lotissement
bien sûr la caducité du cahier des
charges d'un lotissement
s'il n'est pas publié au bureau des
hypothèques dans les cinq ans
c'est je dirais c'est la même remarque
il y avait une insécurité juridique pour
les élus qui étaient importantes
donc nous avons supprimé la commission
des lois a supprimé les articles
concernant cette ces mesures d'urbanisme
en revanche les dispositions relatives
aux conventions demande à la dispense de
diagnostic pour la vente d'immeubles
voué à la destruction et à l'évolution
des projets urbains partenariaux était
précisé afin de résoudre les difficultés
que nous avions repéré que vous aviez
repéré bien nous avons également
supprimé quelque chose qu'il que vous
avez rappelé comme très important et je
suis d'accord avec vous il s'agit de la
fusion des deux structures qui
interviennent en matière de lutte contre
les infections sexuellement
transmissibles
mais la commission a considéré deux
choses qu'on ne pouvait pas prendre
cette décision sans consulter la
commission des affaires sociales et
deuxièmement se poser le problème de la
confidentialité
des personnes et qu'il fallait donc
revenir sur ce sujet mais sur le fond
nous trouvons cette idée tout à fait
juste madame la ministre
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues nous n'allons pas réglé d'un
coup de baguette magique où le comprenez
bien les difficultés résultent résumant
résultant pardon du foisonnement
normatif
je considère cependant qu'avec ce texte
le premier pas et opérer si je puis dire
ce sera un signal très fort même s'il
faudra sûrement y revenir
le renforcement du dispositif de
régulation des normes qui vous est
proposée par la commission des lois
devrait aussi desserrer l'étau qui
enserre la gestion locale encore faut-il
et là je m'adresse à vous mesdames les
ministres que les commissions
la ccn et la cerfres s et les moyens je
dirais de leur mission car comme vous le
savez aujourd'hui les capacités d'action
de ces instances sont assez réduites
même si ils font déjà un énorme travail
sous la présidence de monsieur alain
lambert avec un certain nombre d'élus il
est clair que la sécheresse comme la ccn
manque de moyens notamment de moyens je
dirais matériel et administratifs et
vous savez peut-être qu'aujourd'hui ce
sont des permanents des associations
d'élus qui font office de secrétariat
donc
donc je crois qu'il y à une ardente
obligation à ce que dans l'avenir nous
ayons un renforcement de ses de ces
autorités ce sera je crois un gage de
bon fonctionnement de la démocratie
locale je vous remercie
merci madame nora porter la parole
l'état monsieur martial bourquin
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires économiques
le président madame la ministre
chers collègues voilà maintenant plus
d'un an que le sénat examine la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
doligé preuve s'il en est que la
simplification est décidément beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraît parfois
faire simple c'est compliqué et parfois
en voulant faire simple on peut ajouter
de la complexité à la complexité
je rappellerai que notre assemblée
prenant la mesure de cette inflation
normative s'est à plusieurs reprises
saisi de cette question il ya eu le
rapport belot ont fait vriller 2011 au
nom de la délégation collectivités
locales et à la décentralisation parler
à juste titre de la maladie de la norme
le rapport de notre collègue doligé de
juin 2011 identifiait 268 propositions
aussi variés qu'essentiel pouvant être
simplifiées et bien entendu j'ai été
comme l'ensemble nos collègues très
sensible aux résultats du sondage
réalisé réalisés lors des états généraux
des collectivités territoriales qui
rapportait la nécessité de tous les élus
de simplifier les normes notamment en
matière d'urbanisme et en matière de
marchés publics
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
doligé poursuit donc un objectif qui
fait consensus dans cet hémicycle comme
dans l'ensemble des élus pour autant
chers collègues comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le répéter en commission
et en séance
je crains que le travail ne soit pas
toujours à la hauteur des enjeux qu'ils
soulèvent et qui l'introduit parfois
sous couvert de simplification des
dispositions qui sont proposés sont
sujettes à côte en cieux la commission
d'économie s'intéresse plus précisément
aux articles 19 et 26 de cette
proposition de loi ayant pour trait
urbanisme et tout d'abord je voudrais
dire que je proposais je partage en cela
la position de la commission des lois de
supprimer les articles 20 et 21 23 et 24
26 pour des raisons que je vais
développer
l'article 20 ans un store du secteur de
projets dans lesquels les règlements
d'urbanisme seraient suspendues et où
les objectifs des orientations
d'aménagement et de programmation de
viendrait directement opposables aux
demandes individuelles
tout d'abord si un plan local
d'urbanisme existe et comporte de
nombreuses contraintes
c'est toutefois un urbanisme de projet
et il est toutefois possible de le
modifier assez facilement et ceci
d'autant plus que la plupart d'entre
elles sont facultatives ensuite la
souplesse introduite par cet article ne
serait qu apparente puisqu'en
contrepartie des plus grandes marges de
manoeuvre que vous proposez l'autorité
administrative et récits décision
davantage contesté
l'article 21 relève du réglementaire
puisqu'il prévoit la faculté de
regrouper les dossiers de création et de
réalisation d'une zac l'article 23
modifie les règles de caducité des
clauses de cahier des charges de
lotissement il est à mon sens encore un
anti constitutionnelle puisqu'ils
portent atteinte à la liberté
contractuelle d'écolo dit l'article 24
propose autoriser les promesses de vente
ou de location d'un terrain de l'autisme
en avant avant la délivrance d'un permis
d'aménager cette disposition pourrait
placer les maires devant le fait
accompli
elle ne leur permettraient plus la
liberté de négocier sereinement les
actes signés ou d'éventuelles
modifications du projet enfin l'article
6 qui limite les obligations imposées
par le pnud en matière d'aires de
stationnement
vous conviendrez
est un cavalier législatif voilà pour
les modifications et réserve
j'approuve par ailleurs compte tenu des
amendements rédactionnels prévu prévu
par notre notre notre collègue
rapporteur l'article 10 qui simplifie le
recours au mandat en matière
d'aménagement ainsi que l'article 22 qui
dispense d'un certain nombre de
diagnostics les bâtiments en vente en
vue d'être détruit
d'évidence l'article 25 qui en cas de la
négociation d'une convention du projet
urbain partenarial chers collègues je
rajouterais à ce propos une opinion
toute personnelle la simplification des
normes est un grand sujet pour être moi
même mère je constate tous les jours
l'adaf hic la difficulté de mener des
projets le rallongement souvent de ses
projets suite à ce maquis que
représentent les normes
je crois qu'il est nécessaire que nous
atteignons à la tâche mais de façon
peut-être plus approfondie en s'appuyant
par exemple sur les résultats de l'
enquête des ateliers des états généraux
des collectivités territoriales un
travail de fond est nécessaire et notre
collègue doligé a le mérite de poser le
problème a le mérite d'aborder des
questions mais cependant beaucoup de
questions restent en suspens et méritent
encore d'être approfondie il faut pour
cela une certaine distance et il faut
surtout ne pas rajouter de la complexité
à la complexité
combien une fois en voulant simplifier
nous avons complexifier nous avons mené
avec plusieurs collègues qui sont ici
une une mission d'information sur la
désindustrialisation et la
réindustrialisation
nous avons
nous avons nous avons dans tous les
territoires où nous sommes rendus
lula le constat mais non seulement le
constat mais la demande pressante des
chefs d'entreprise de responsables d'
agences de développement
nous disons simplifiée faisons en sorte
que la création d'entreprise soit plus
simple faisons en sorte que les projets
puissent aboutir plus facilement
parfois c'était dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui nous disait qu'un
projet instruit demander parfois deux
ans deux ans et demi avant de voir le
jour alors qu'un produit a une durée de
vie de 5 ans tout cela nous devons mener
ce travail de front en même temps
faisons en sorte que nous ayons la
distance la profondeur nécessaire pour
justement aboutir à ce que nous
simplifions certainement que nous
rendions plus compétitive notre
industrie et nos entreprises on
simplifiant parce que lorsqu'on aborde
la compétitivité on avance souvent la
question des coûts et pas assez la
compétitivité hors coûts et ça fait
partie la compétitivité hors coûts et
enfin nous avons besoin d'une société
plus dynamiques qui a une fluidité et ce
travail de simplification est absolument
nécessaire et c'est pour cela que nous
juste souscrivons avec les
recommandations que j'ai j'ai formulées
durant cette intervention
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean jacques lozach rapporteur
pour avis de la commission de la culture
mais monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues nous voici
réunis pour examiner la proposition de
loi de monsieur eric doligé visant à
simplifier les normes applicables aux
collectivités locales la commission des
lois nous a délégué l'examen au fond de
l'article 27 relatifs à l'archéologie
préventive tandis que notre commission a
décidé de se saisir pour avis de l'
article premier supprimé par la
commission des lois et de l'article 2 le
premier posé le principe d' adaptation
des normes à la taille des collectivités
il était notamment relatifs aux
dérogations aux normes d'accessibilité
au regard des contraintes liées à la
préservation du patrimoine architectural
le second article temps à compléter le
code du sport pour soumettre le décret
et les règlements fédéraux à l'avis de
la commission consultative d'évaluation
des normes
créé en 2008 est par ailleurs réformé
par la présente proposition de loi notre
assemblée avait décidé sur proposition
de la commission des lois du renvoi en
commission de ce texte lors de la séance
publique du 15 février dernier
je dois dire que ce choix de procédure a
été très utile pour approfondir notre
examen
en outre le calendrier aura été
judicieux puisque certains sujets
abordés dans ce texte sont aujourd'hui
au coeur de l'actualité
à commencer par le sujet de l'inflation
normative je rappelle que l'auteur
monsieur doligé indiqué que trois
préoccupations essentielles l'avait
guidé la réduction des coûts et des
contraintes normatives l'accélération
des procédures administratives
structurant les projets des
collectivités et l'instauration d'un
dialogue autour de l'activité normative
ces questions sont évidemment partagé
par bon nombre d'élus locaux toujours
préoccupé par les situations complexes
auxquels sont confrontés les
collectivités dès le 4 septembre à
l'occasion des rencontres
départementales des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale de la drôme
le président du sénat avait clairement
identifiés l'inflation des normes comme
l'un des sujets majeurs pour nos
territoires
notre président alors précisé les deux
batailles à mener de front
je cite la première consiste à enrayer
la machine à produire de nouvelles
normes toujours plus exigeantes en
ressources financières ou humaines
la seconde à simplifier le droit
existant en élaguant nos codes et
prescription obligatoire de tout ce qui
n'est pas aussi nécessaire que nous
l'avons cru quand ils ont été édités
s'inscrivant dans cette même ligne de
pensée le président de la république a
réaffirmé le 5 octobre dernier à
l'occasion des états généraux organisés
par le sénat que je cite la confiance
c'est l'allègement des normes 400000
norme serait applicable est en mesure a
évoqué ce chiffre
combien la décentralisation et
finalement contourné détourné d'alors
qu'il ya autant de contraintes qui
pèsent sur les collectivités
ces dernières sont victimes de
l'inflation normative qui pèse en
particulier sur les compétences
transférées et qu'il devient une source
de coûts croissants coûts liés aux
investissements concernés au personnel a
déployé à l'organisation qui découle de
l'application des mesures etc
le rapport sur les relations entre
l'état les collectivités locales de
notre ancien collègue alain lambert
souligné déjà en 2007 la problématique
de la libre administration des
collectivités
dans ce contexte de croissance normative
exponentielle dans bien des domaines
environnement solidarité et cohésion
sociale sécurité alimentaire fonction
publique culture etc
les collectivités sont insuffisamment
associés à la production normative qui
en s'imposant apparaît comme une entorse
à la décentralisation
or la gouvernance dans bâti doit être
partagé le rôle de financeur et de
maître d'ouvragé des collectivités
justifie pleinement qu'elles soient des
acteurs incontournables de la
concertation préalable à la définissant
de nouvelles normes comme l'a précisé
jean pierre bel le sujet de la
régulation des normes est complexe car
il ne s'agit pas de déréglementer à tout
va mais de rechercher résolument les
pistes d'une réelle avancée c'est
précisément l'objectif que nous nous
sommes fixés
en examinant les dispositions figurant
dans la présente proposition de loi
l'équilibré délicat à trouver
et je crois que plus que jamais il faut
se donner les moyens d'évaluer
sérieusement les dispositifs existants
de prendre le temps d'apprécier ce qui
est ou non indispensables pour mener à
bien une politique publique
je crois à la vertu de la réflexion et
de l'évaluation
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a guidé la
commission de la culture dans son
analyse des propositions relatives à
l'archéologie préventive contenues dans
ce texte comme dans l'examen de certains
amendements extérieur sur lesquels nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir
nous sommes respectueux des travaux
menés par les élus comme par des experts
nous sommes respectueux des actions de
concertation donné pour apprécier la
pertinence un dispositif et d'un
ensemble normatif
c'est pourquoi vous le verrez dans notre
position notre commission a fait le
choix de ne pas réformer aujourd'hui
l'archéologie préventive ou encore les
procédures de protection prévue par le
code du patrimoine au détour d'un
amendement extérieur ces dispositions
dont on perçoit bien la logique et les
motivations nous semble faire table rase
du travail de fonds considérables menés
par notre assemblée à l'unanimité lors
du grenelle de l'environnement ou du
travail à venir avec le projet de loi
sur les patrimoines qui va nous être
soumise en 2013
comme l'a rappelé à plusieurs mini à
plusieurs reprises la ministre de la
culture alléger l'énorme sans prendre le
temps de la réflexion et de la
concertation veut donner l'illusion
d'une plus grande liberté accordée aux
collectivités territoriales il est
certes tentant de modifier un élément
circonscrit d'un dispositif ou d'une
procédure
mais si cela crée de nouveaux
dysfonctionnements parce que nous
n'avons pas anticiper les répercussions
sur l'ensemble de la politique publique
alors on ne fait que créer de nouvelles
contraintes que les collectivités
devront à nouveau gérer victimes de
l'instabilité juridique
après avoir été victime de l'inflation
normative
comme le dit jean-pierre bel le sujet
n'est pas facile je pense que le
législateur doit être capable
d'apprécier les paradoxes d'une démarche
de simplification normative paradoxe qui
ne sont pas sans rappeler la phrase de
cicéron nous sommes esclaves des lois
pour pouvoir être libre
faisons donc attention à ne pas créer de
nouvelles entraves à la liberté
d'administration de nos collectivités et
selon et cela en pensant bien faire en
pensant simplifier leur environnement
législatif et réglementaire
j'en viens maintenant au coeur des
sujets traités par la commission de la
culture
je commencerai si vous le voulez bien
par l'article 27 qui nous a été déléguée
au fond et pour lequel nous avons adopté
un amendement de suppression
la nouvelle rédaction du deuxième alinéa
de l'article 7 523 c'est du coeur du
patrimoine proposé initialement par cet
article vise et je cite à permettre
l'aboutissement des conventions de
diagnostic dans des délais compatibles
avec des opérations d'aménagement
l'article 27 introduisez un nouveau
délai dans le texte notre collègue eric
doligé la convention doit être signée
dans un délai de deux mois à compter de
sa réception par la personne projetant
d'exécuter les travaux
à défaut de signature de la convention
dans ce délai le représentant de l'état
dans le département peut être saisie par
une des parties est fixé la date de
début de réalisation des diagnostics
si le défaut de signature est lié à un
désaccord sur certaines dispositions
ces dernières sont déterminées par le
préfet de département
en l'absence de décision de ce dernier
dans un délai fixé par décret en conseil
d'état
la prescription est réputé caduque il
n'est évidemment pas question pour nous
d'éluder le problème des délais que
notre ancien collègue yves dauge ainsi
que pierre bordier avait déjà mise en
évidence dans leur rapport de juillet
2011 relatif à l'archéologie préventive
il avait d'ailleurs précisément souligné
le problème de la durée de conclusion de
la convention qui en l'absence de
contraintes normatives a pu constituer
une marge de manoeuvre exploiter de
façon abusive dans certains cas sur le
fond nous soucier vont à toute démarche
visant ainsi à améliorer le droit
existant et à fluidifier la chaîne de
l'archéologie préventive depuis la
présentation du projet d'aménagement
jusqu'à la production du rapport de
fouilles
mais il ne s'agit pas pour autant
d'alléger aujourd'hui les nord
au mépris de la cohérence de l'ensemble
normatif ou de la sécurité juridique des
différents acteurs or une étape décisive
de l'archéologie préventive est en train
de se dessiner lors des journées
nationales de l'archéologie du 22 juin
dernier la ministre de la culture
annoncé la constitution d'une commission
d'évaluation scientifique économique et
social de l'archéologie préventive
installé très récemment le 5 octobre
cette commission a pour mission de
rendre un livre blanc de l'archéologie
préventive au plus tard au mois de mars
les propositions devraient être reprises
dans le volet archéologie du projet de
loi sur les patrimoines également
annoncée pour 2013
dans un tel contexte il serait
préjudiciable de modifier un seul
article du code du patrimoine
alors que l'ensemble du système va être
analysé et évalué et éventuellement
repenser ce serait une source
d'instabilité juridique s'impose entente
aux membres de la commission
d'évaluation qu acteur de l'archéologie
préventive
y compris donc aux collectivités
territoriales qui risquerait de devoir
une fois de plus s'adapter à deux
changements normatif successifs et cela
en moins d'un an
si l'objectif défendu par l'article 27 &
noble il paraît néanmoins nécessaire de
ne pas se lancer aujourd'hui dans une
réforme
compte tenu du contexte que je viens
d'évoquer pardon j'ajoute une réforme du
financement de l'archéologie préventive
initié par la loi financement
rectificatif du 28 décembre 2011 est en
cours et se poursuit avec le projet de
loi de finances pour 2013 parallèlement
à cette réforme qui devrait déboucher
sur un versement de la redevance
d'archéologie préventive à la
réalisation des travaux et non plus en
début d'année une réforme de la
gouvernance de l'inrap a été initiée via
un contrat de performance afin que
toutes les conditions soient réunies
pour accélérer les chantiers et le
traitement des dossiers par
l'établissement public
concernant le fond de l'article 27
je rappelle que la rédaction du deuxième
alinéa de l'article l 523 7 du code du
patrimoine
proposée initialement soulevait
plusieurs difficultés tout d'abord elle
confié un rôle de médiateurs et arbitres
au préfet de département alors que c'est
le préfet de région qui intervient à
tous les stades de mise en oeuvre de la
politique d'archéologie préventive
ensuite ce texte imposé une signature
dans les deux mois suivant la réception
du projet de convention sans préciser
certaines conditions essentielles telles
que les garanties de libération des
terrains concernés qui constitue
pourtant une information indispensable à
l'arrêt d'une date de début de travaux
de diagnostic
en outre il est difficile d'apporter une
réponse globalisante en termes de délais
pour des projets d'aménagement très
diverses dont la nature les coûts et
l'intérêt général peuvent
considérablement varier
enfin le fait que le préfet de
département puisse imposer aux deux
parties non seulement les délais mais
aussi des dispositions contenues dans la
convention peut sembler d'autant plus
dangereux que s'ils ne tranche pas les
différentes questions dans un délai fixé
par décret la prescription est réputé
caduque cette disposition me semble
particulièrement critiquable et toutes
les personnes auditionnées sur le sujet
partage ce point de vue en effet la
caducité n'efface pas les vestiges
archéologiques dont on présume la
présence sur les terrains pour lesquels
des diagnostics ont été prescrits cela
signifie que si l'aménageur débutent les
travaux et tombe sur des vestiges alors
la loi du 27 septembre 1941 modifiée
portant réglementation des fouilles
archéologiques s'appliquera son titre
iii codifiée aux articles l 531 14 et
suivants du code du patrimoine prévoit
qu'en cas de découverte fortuite
le chantier doit être immédiatement
arrêtées les terrains étant considéré
comme classés autant dire que la
solution proposée par l'article 27
serait pire en termes de coûts et de
perturbations pour les collectivités que
ne l'est la situation actuelle pour
toutes ces raisons notre commission a
adopté un amendement de suppression de
l'article 27
elle a également et en toute logique
adopté un avis défavorable à
l'amendement extérieur proposer sur cet
article qui propose une version légère
modifiée de la rédaction initiale je
souhaiterais maintenant aborder les
articles pour lesquels la commission de
la culture s'est saisie pour avis il
s'agit tout d'abord de l'article 1er qui
selon l'auteur visait à introduire dans
le droit positif et plus précisément
dans le code général des collectivités
territoriales le principe de
proportionnalité des normes et celui de
leur adaptation à la taille des
collectivités
cet article a été supprimée par la
commission des lois
je dois avec je dois avouer que nous
étions dubitatif quant à la mise en
oeuvre d'un principe d'adaptation et
donc de dérogations aux lois accordant
une très grande large part
d'appréciation au pouvoir réglementaire
là encore il s'agit d'un sujet que le
président du sénat n'a pas manqué
d'aborder lors de son discours de
clôture des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale jean pierre bel
a défini les limites du principe
d'adaptation qui ont justifié la
suppression de l'article 1er ainsi at-il
dit que je cite nous pourrons aussi
réfléchir un pouvoir d'adaptation locale
de la loi faut prendre en compte lorsque
l'intérêt général le justifient les
particularités du territoire
bien sûr le chef de l'état l'a indiqué
un tel pouvoir ne pourrait être général
car le risque d'affaiblir le principe
d'égalité des citoyens devant la loi
fondement de notre république serait
trop grand mais l'uniformité ne garantit
pas l'égalité
il faudra trouver un équilibre fin de
citation
je ne vais pas revenir sur l'ensemble de
l'article 1er qui figurait dans le texte
initial mais je souhaite on aime
rappeler que le grand hall de cet
article prévoyait ainsi que la loi
puisse autoriser le préfet de
département à prendre des mesures
dérogatoires les dispositions étaient en
sus de décliner dans trois domaines qui
saoule à des difficultés particulières
dont celui des établissements recevant
du public
ainsi étaient prises en compte et
contraintes liées à la conservation du
patrimoine architectural le préfet de
département pouvait ainsi constater les
difficultés particulières que cela
induit selon des règles précisées par
décret en conseil d'état qui détermine
des dérogations de plein droit alors que
celle ci relève aujourd'hui d'une
faculté accordée à titre exceptionnel si
la prise en compte des contraintes liées
à la conservation du patrimoine
architectural
ne soulève pas de difficulté
particulière de notre point de vue nous
nous étions interrogés dès le début sur
la portée de la disposition prévoyant de
façon très générale un système
dérogatoire
nous avions en effet constaté que le
texte ne donnait pas d'indications
précises sur la façon dont seraient
définies les mesures dérogatoires
on ne peut imaginer que la loi n'encadre
pas davantage de pouvoirs réglementaires
pour que ce dernier puisse s'appuyer sur
des critères suffisamment précis sinon
on risque d'aboutir à une application à
la carte de la loi chaque préfet de
département pour en apprécier
différemment l'ampleur des adaptations
nécessaires déroger à la loi nécessite
un cadre juridique plus précis que le
législateur doit donner non pas de façon
générale mais à l'occasion de chaque loi
qui nécessite de prévoir de telles
mesures d'adaptation
évoquant ensuite l'article 2 sur lequel
la commission de la culture a donné un
avis sont grandes de avait initialement
pour objet de soumettre les évolutions
des normes sportives prévues par les
fédérations à un avis de la commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes
je n'ai pas besoin d'insister devant
l'ensemble des parlementaires sous
l'important de cette question qui
constitue un enjeu réel pour des
collectivités
les modifications des normes sur les
équipements sportifs peut en effet avoir
de lourdes conséquences pour les
communes propriétaire à 80 % des
structures sportives bien souvent sans
que l'intérêt de l'évolution soit majeur
pour le sport en question
l'assemblée nationale avait présenté un
rapport d'information sur ce thème dès
2005 qui avait conduit à la mise en
place en 2009 de la commission d'examen
des règlements fédéraux relatifs aux
équipements sportifs c'est à dire la
cerfres s en 2011 rapport de monsieur
doligé sur la simplification des normes
applicables aux collectivités locales
dressez cependant un constat sévère sur
cette question en faisant état d'
absence récurrente de saisine préalable
de la cerfres s d'une représentation
insuffisante des collectivités de la
perfectibilité des notice d'impact de
conditions de classement fédéral
discutable ou bien encore de délai
d'application peu raisonnable lors de
ses travaux sur cette proposition de loi
la commission de la culture s'est vu
confirmer notamment par l'association
des élus en charge du sport landais ce
que les inquiétudes étaient nourris sur
les évolutions ininterrompue des normes
sportives qui d'ailleurs émane parfois
de fédérations sportives nationales mais
parfois de fédération internationale
elles sont censé s'appliquer aux clubs
et non directement collectivités mais
c'est bien au final les communes qui
sont mis sous pression pour mettre à
niveau les équipements
l'idée d'imposer un avis de la ccn sur
ces normes sportives poser cependant
problème en effet elle n'est supposé
donner d'avis que sur les normes
s'appliquant directement collectivités
territoriales ou à leurs groupements
ce qui n'est pas le cas des normes sur
lesquels la serre ferait donne un avis
outre ce problème de fond la surcharge
de travail de la commission d'évaluation
des normes risquer de largement
simplifié il apparaît donc que la
solution tendant à renforcer la
représentation des collectivités
territoriales au sein même de la cerfres
s était plus pertinentes sur le fond
comment prince comme en pratique c'est
l'objet de l'article 2 bis introduit par
la commission des lois qui a en
parallèle supprimer les dispositions
relatives aux normes sportives dans
l'article 2
cet article prévoit l'inscription dans
la loi de l'existant de la cerfres s
mais également une composition à parité
entre les représentants des
collectivités territoriales et les
autres membres considérant que ces
dispositions répondait de lacunes de
notre droit et à une demande des
collectivités territoriales la
commission de la culture a donné un avis
favorable aux dispositions prévues par
l'article de vis voilà madame la
ministre chers collègues les réflexions
qui nous ont guidés
ainsi la commission de la culture a
donné un avis favorable à l'adoption des
dispositions ainsi présenté dans le
texte de la commission des lois
sous réserve des habits que je viens de
vous présenter concernant les
abonnements qui nous étaient soumis je
vous remercie de votre attention
merci chers collègues voilà pour cette
séance consacrée entre autres à la
simplification des normes nous y
reviendrons bien entendu plus largement
dans notre journal
19h présenté ce soir par michel
grossiord bonne fin de journée à tous
moi